brandon ate five slices of apple of pie
i'm just assuming it's apple pie they
didn't tell me that gabriella ate three
slices if they're originally nine slices
what fraction of the pie was eaten so
let me let me see if i can draw
draw this thing out
so let me draw the pie
i will draw the pie in a yellowish color
so let me try my best
so let's see how well good i am at
drawing a pie so i'll just draw it from
the top view as a circle
and there are nine slices i think it's a
reasonable assumption to say that there
are nine equal slices
so we have nine equal slices of pie and
i'll just make sure they're initially
nine
equal equal slices what fraction of the
pie was in so let's first divide this
into nine sections
so one way i could do that i could
divide it into three sections first
three sections first looks like a piece
symbol
actually looks more like the mercedes
emblem so i'll draw it into three
sections first and i'll do each of those
into three sections and i'll have nine
so let's see i'll draw like
like that
and like that
try my keep in mind i'm trying to make
these as equal as possible
so bear with me if they don't look 100
equal but i'm trying
i am trying my best so nine equal
nine equal slices so that looks that
looks pretty respectable so here's our
our pie that initially had nine equal
slices now they tell us that brandon
ate five slices of pie so brandon eats
it seems like a hungry young man so he
eats one
two
three
four
five you could say that he ate five
ninths of the pie but that's not it
that's not what they're asking this
thing total not just how much did
brandon eat but how much was eaten total
between gab between brandon and
gabriella and they tell us gabriella ate
three slices
so she ate one sounds like they didn't
really eat dinner
one
two
three so now let's answer their question
what fraction of the pie was eaten well
we know that there was a total of nine
nine equal slices of pie what fraction
was eaten well as you see one two three
four five six
seven eight
eight ninths of the pie was eaten
so let's actually type that in and then
we will do it right over here we say
eight and we use that little slash
symbol on your computer like this eight
over
nine or eight divided by nine or eight
ninths of the pie was eaten
let's do a couple more of these
ishan ate two slices of pizza omar ate
three slices if they're originally eight
slices what fraction of the pie
is remaining
so this is interesting actually let me
let me copy and paste this so that i can
do it on my little on my little
notepad right over here
so let's
let's do it right over trying to find
some space there you go
let me put that in here
so same thing we have a well this is a
pizza now not a pie
and so pizza i will draw in brown it has
eight and we can assume it's initially
eight equal slices
eight equal slices so let me it's
actually a little bit easier draw eight
equal slices since eight is an even
number
so let's see so let's that is my best
attempt at drawing a circle
and let's see first i can divide the
pizza into two slices
then i can divide it into four slices
four and i'm gonna try to make them look
as equal as possible
and now i'm gonna with two more cuts i
should be able to get eight so
and one more just like this
so there you have it a pizza that has
eight equal slices now they tell us
ishan ate two slices of pizza so he eats
one
two slices of pizza
omar ate three slices omar ate three so
he eats one
two
one two
three slices of pizza
now you might immediately say oh okay
the answer to this must be one two three
four five it must be that they ate five
slices of pizza over a total of eight
slices of pizza so they ate five eighths
of the pizza you would be right and
saying that they ate five eighths of the
pizza because they ate one two three
four five out of a total of eight pieces
but that's not what this what this
question is asking they are asking what
fraction of the pizza is remaining so
what's left over after ishaan and omar
had their go at the pizza well what's
remaining is one
two
three slices so what's remaining is
three
out of the original eight
equal parts or three eighths of the
pizza is remaining so let's input that
so we could go right here and we would
say 3 over 8. 3 8 is remaining so let's
check our answer and we got it right